Senator Lee just had a wonderful
exchange with a a woman who is from the
Independent Women's Law Center on the
topic of sex and gender but not
specifically on the topic of
transgenderism
he actually dug into an issue that goes
back much further
and it goes a lot deeper
an issue where
if we want to really get at the heart
of our present crazy sexual gender
Madness
which is dominating the headlines as all
the libs want to talk about and
therefore the conservatives have to talk
about it because it's upending society
that issue
is before
transgenderism before redefining
marriage before all the crazy sexual
Revolution stuff it goes all the way
back to feminism and the feminist
would-be Constitutional Amendment called
the era the Equal Rights Amendment which
would destroy women's rights in America
Senator Lee has recently dug into
a recurrent an almost perennial leftist
issue it's been cropping up since the
70s it's called the era the Equal Rights
Amendment this is the feminist
Constitutional Amendment that ironically
though not so ironically if you really
understand feminism but seems ironically
would destroy rights for women in
America and the era the libs have been
trying to ratify this thing for decades
now people don't actually want it which
is why I keep stalling out but Senator
Lee asked Jennifer braceres who's at the
Independent Women's Law Center what the
era really would look like in practice
what might this do
for sex-segregated prisons prisons for
women what might this do for
government-sponsored government-funded
and operated uh shelters for uh for
Abused Women for example or public
restrooms locker rooms athletic
facilities athletic competitions what
might strict scrutiny do to every one of
those so in the racial context courts
have been very clear that prisons cannot
separate inmates on the basis of race
even where doing so would prevent
certain gang
violence in the prison and that's that's
the right standard they should not be
able to separate inmates on the basis of
race if you apply that same standard to
men and women that would mean that
prisons could never they would have to
have co-ed prisons you could never
separate inmates on the basis of sex
and male and female prisoners would have
to be housed together
that's right ladies we're gonna bring
you progress we're gonna liberate you
women by forcing you to bunk up with big
gigantic Bubba over there when you're in
prison what could go wrong isn't that
great isn't that progress reminds me of
a line from Lucille Ball Lucille Ball
was asked during an interview I think
maybe with Dick Cavett many decades ago
what she thought about women's lib and
she said I think I'm liberated enough I
think I could use a little less
Liberation I don't think women's lib has
made women very very happy and you can
see this in study after study take
studies of happiness with a grain of
salt but all of them seem to show that
women have become much less happy since
women's lib came about both relative to
men and in absolute terms
the era would do all sorts of other
things would it effectively abolish
women's bathrooms the transgender
activists are trying to do that already
would effectively ban women's sports
would would end women's schools and all
the special rights and spaces that women
have specifically for themselves right
now how did this thing come about
well the era actually was not first
proposed in the 70s it became to
prominence in the 70s the era that was
first proposed in 1923. this was the
first version of it written by Alice
Paul and Crystal Eastman and it was
introduced into Congress didn't get very
far
then there's another move to revive in
the 1970s Congress set a ratification
deadline of March 22nd 1979. by 1977 the
era had received 35 of the necessary 38
states to ratify it so the feminists
realized it wasn't going to work to get
this thing through Congress people
didn't want it but if they if they tried
to surreptitiously go through all of the
different states and get it ratified
they might over time push this thing
through so they were so close in 1977 at
35 out of 38 States and then Along Came
not some man some patriarchal
misogynistic man to put those women in
their place no Along Came
a little lady by the name of Phyllis
Schlafly a conservative woman one of the
most important conservative leaders in
America certainly of the 20th century
really I would say ever
she was a religious mother of six I
believe and she rallied women around
America not the women that the feminists
like not the crazy hair burning their
bras woman needs a man like a fish needs
a bicycle kind of feminist ladies
but normal regular women who love their
husbands who love their sons who love
their home life who love their special
privileges and places and rights and
spaces in society rally those women
around America and said no we don't want
this progress that would destroy our
role in society
that point five State legislatures Idaho
Kentucky Nebraska Tennessee South Dakota
voted to revoke their era ratifications
so they'd already ratified it they said
nope we don't want this thing anymore
the first four rescinded their
ratification before the original 1979
deadline South Dakota did so by voting
to Sunset the ratification as of the
original deadline so the original
deadline hits okay no more era because
they couldn't get it through in 1978 the
libs kept it up Congress passed by
simple majorities in each house and and
Jimmy Carter signed as president a joint
resolution to extend the deadline which
is legally a little bit dubious but they
said okay we couldn't get the damn thing
through well all right let's push it a
few more years 1982 and then guess what
happened in those three years no
additional State legislatures ratified
the era because nobody wants it because
it's insane
then in 2020 just three years ago
Virginia's General Assembly passed a
ratification resolution for the era
which then claimed to bring that number
up to 38. but of course it did not there
are so many reasons that obviously
didn't work they've blown through
deadline after deadline in order to
claim that they had 38 States they would
have to ignore the fact that five State
legislatures withdrew their ratification
it's just nonsense they keep but this is
what the libs do they just doggedly
pursue their agenda even if the people
hate it even if it's not particularly
legal or constitutional they just
they're they're like a dog with a bone
they don't let go that's why they
generally win and the culture War stuff
the reason I mention this now is to be
on the alert because they're they're
going to keep pushing for this and we
need to shoot it down it would be
terrible for women to be terrible for
society but also to point out
that there's a line that some
conservatives have used in recent years
that it's not true they'll say look we
hate
second wave feminism that's the broad
burners of the 70s that second wave
feminism was bad
the Third Way of feminism which was I
don't know it was like the 90s 2000s
that was also bad and now I think we're
in the fourth wave I don't know or if
the 50th wave whatever wave we're in
that's also bad but this is what they
would say they'll say the first wave
feminists they were really good
those first wave feminists back in the
20s they were the good ones and it's not
true they're all the same people they're
all the same feminism is just bad okay
it's bad because it posits and this is
the same issue that we see with
transgenderism
it posits a false anthropology
it suggests that there is no meaningful
difference between men and women
the traditional way of viewing men and
women is that men and women are
different Men Are from Mars Women Are
from Venus men and women go together
you're never going to have a war between
the Sexes because everybody's Sleeping
with the Enemy oh man and we will never
understand each other but that's what
adds spice to life and we love that and
that's why men and women are coupled
with one another human beings or a
coupling species and we come together
and by golly we can procreate isn't that
so amazing it's only through the union
of a man and a woman that we can
actually partake of God's creation
because what we what we can do without
one another is we can you know I can
produce this show and though I need a
whole Army of people to actually you
know make the show happen but we can
always all do that we can make a work of
art we can write a poem we can bake a
pie but in order to partake of actual
creation not just putting stuff together
and building it but actually creating
new life
you need men and women together that's
the old way of viewing things the modern
view the feminist views that men and
women don't need each other they're
they're basically the same anyway it
gets a little confusing because the
feminists would argue that men and women
certainly have the same brains and their
their physical differences are just
superficial they only run Skin Deep
whereas the transgenderists now claim
that men and women have totally
different brains which is how men who
think they're women they actually
allegedly have the brain of a woman or
something like that which irritates many
of the feminists because the feminists
say who the hell are you to tell me that
my brain isn't the same as a man's brain
and so they'll try to Duke it out but
it's it all derives from the same false
anthropology yes the second way
feminists were bad they're all bad
though because it's all wrong it's
either true or false it happens to be
false and we should oppose this stuff
this is going to be the topic of my
speech in Buffalo I'm giving a speech
with Young Americans Foundation up at
the University of Buffalo on Thursday
very very excited for that the topic
that I've been requested to speak on is
feminism and you know since I Am The
Love Guru here at the daily wire Dr
romance I I have I have many thoughts on
this topic and and thoughts on the topic
of sex and gender in politics more
broadly because where conservatives are
always just fighting on the terms of the
left so now we're fighting over whether
or not we should trans the
eight-year-olds if not the nine-year-old
so we're fighting over whether we should
abolish women's sports we've gotta we've
got to go a little bit deeper we've got
to take on
the feminists the rest of the show
continues now you don't want to miss it
become a member use code Knowles Canada
w-l-e-s at checkout for two months free
on all annual plans
[Music]